السعوديه من اكثر الدول في ارتفاع معدلات
الاصابه بامراض القلب والشرايين التاجيه
هذا ما دعى المجلس الصحي السعودي لاطلاق
معايير جديده للتعامل معه المصابين حيث
تعد امراض القلب المسبب الاول للوفاء في
السعوديه بنسبه تتخطى 37% من اجمالي
الوفيات واثبتت الدراسات ان 54% من
مواطنيه السعوديه ما بين 30 الى 70 عاما
يعانون من ارتفاع شديد في الكوليسترول وهو
العامل الاخضر في الاصابه بامراض القلب
دراسات اخرى متلازمه الشرايين التاجيه
والازمات القلب يتصل الى 40 الف حاله
جديده كل عام في السعوديه فقط وان المرضى
السعوديين يصابون بمتلازمه الشرايين عند
عمر 58 سنه وهو يعد اصغر ب 10 سنوات عن
معدل الاعمار في العالم
مجددا ينضم الينا مدير عام المركز الوطني
للقلب الدكتور عبد عادل عبد القادر طاش
دكتور عادل مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
دكتور يعني اول شيء اذا ما توقفنا عن عن
عند الارقام
37 في المئه امراض القلب هي المسبب الاول
للوفاه السعوديه 54% من مواطن السعوديه
يعانون من ارتفاع الشديد وغيرها من
الارقام التي وردت في هذا التقرير اعتقد
انها ارقام خطيره وربما يعني لم تصل بشكل
مفاجئ كانت مبنيه على تراكمات في عده
سنوات ماضيه ليس كذلك
نعم اولا شكرا استاذ خالد على الاستضافه
وسعيد بوجودكم ولكن حقيقه يعني زي ما
تفضلتم في التقرير السابق لابد ان اا يعني
ااا نبدا بالعمل الكبير
والحديث على الحد من عوامل خطوره الاصابه
بممتازمه الشريان التاجي او الجلطات
القلبيه الحاده في المجتمع السعودي فحقيقه
زي ما تفضلتوا في التقرير المجتمع السعودي
مختلف عن المجتمع الغربي من الاشياء
الحقيقه اللي احنا لاحظناها ما بين
المجتمع الغربي وما بين المجتمع السعودي
بانه المجتمع السعودي احنا نرى مرضى
مصابين بجلطات قلبي حاده في اعمار صغيره
واثبتت الدراسات بانه الاعمار همم اصغر ب
10 سنين يعني احنا في المجتمع السعودي
نصاب بالجلطات القلبيه الحاده بما يعادل
10 سنين همم همم اصغر من المجتمعات
الغربيه اقل نعم وهذا يدل على انه عوامل
خطوره عندنا اشد وعوامل خطوره عندنا تاخذ
فتره تقليشها ما نتعامل معها حتى تصاب ليش
ليش وصلنا الى هذه الارقام
مع الاشاره انا ابحث عن الموضوع لقيت انه
القضيه صار لها سنوات يعني يعني تقريبا
قبل ثلاثه او اربعه او خمسه سنوات كان مثل
هذا التقرير يشير الى خطوره الامر
نعم صحيح والحقيقه يعني خلال الفتره
الماضيه خلال السنوات الماضيه اخذنا يعني
خطوات جدا جدا ممتازه منها على سبيل
المثال اللجنه او اللجنه الوطنيه لمكافحه
التبغ قللت من همم استخدام او التدخين
بنسبه جيده في المجتمع السعودي لسه عندنا
المشوار ولسه عندنا شوط حلو قطعنا شوط
ولكن عندنا اشواط اخرى ولكن اللجنه
الوطنيه
برنامج جوده الحياه وهمم يعني سنه المدن
همم زادت من اماكن المشي وممارسه الرياضه
وايضا ال- ال- الوزاره الصحه بوجود
العيادات الصحيه الاوليه او مراكز الصحيه
الاوليه زاد هذا كله ممتاز بس الارقام
مرضى نعم نعم تقول غير كده انه اليوم انت
بتتكلم عن 40 الف حاله جديده في كل عام في
السعوديه فقط
وبرجعلك لنفس السؤال ليش احنا بتزيد عندنا
الحالات بهذا الشكل
والله يا حقيقه ان احنا يعني زي ما يعني
قلت لك في البدايه ان احنا اخذنا قطعنا
اشواط في بعضها في السكري في التدخين في
الارتفاع الضغط الدم في انسنه المدن وجوده
الحياه وزياده همم
الجوده الغذاء ولكن في جانب من الجوانب
الحقيقه مازلنا نعاني من هو اللي هو
ارتفاع الكوليسترول من الملاحظ بانه 54%
من ال- همم المواطنين السعوديين ما بين 30
الى 70 سنه مصابين بالارتفاع على الشديد
في الكوليسترول ونعني هنا بالكولسترول
اللي هو الكوليسترول قليل الكثافه
الكوليسترول الضار والحقيقه هذا بيسبب ما
زال عندنا بيسبب اشكاليه
وان احنا عندنا في المجلس الصحي السعودي
وفي وزاره الصحه لدينا الان حملات توعويه
بنصل للناس اكل اكل الكوليسترول اكل بنسبه
عاليه من الدهون والكوليسترو التالي هذه
الارقام تتوام مع طبيعتنا وثقافتنا في
الاكل ولا في اسباب ثانيه
لا طبعا هو في الاكل السبب مسبب ولكن مسبب
فرعي في مسبب رئيسي اللي هو وجود نسبه
كبيره من المجتمع السعودي عندهم ارتفاع
الكوليسترول الوراثي او ما نسميه بفاميليا
هايبر كوليستريليا هترو زايدز فاميليا
الهايبر كوليستروليميا واللي محتاج همم
حقيقه انه نحن نبذل مجهود اكبر
لاكتشاف وعلاجه ولو والمساله انه ايش
بالنسبه لتفاعل الكولسترول الوراثي له
علاج وفي همم يعني احنا نستطيع التحكم
بنسبه الكوليسترول بشكل كبير جدا فمثلا
على سبيل المثال عندنا الادويه ال- ال-
همم اللي نسبه الكوليسترول عاده هذه
نستخدمها في الوقايه الاوليه وبعدين بعد
كده المرضى اذا جاءوا جلطات قلبي حاده
نسبه اللي يرجع بجلطات قلبيه حاده اخرى
ثانيه وثالثه ورابعه خلال الاربعه سنوات
بعد الجلطه الاولى تقريبا واحد الى ثلاثه
يعني يعني ثلث المرضى بيرجعوا ثاني كيف
نحن نستطيع ان نقلل هذه النسبه بشكل جيد
وبشكل ممتاز انه نحنا نقلل من الكوليسترول
الضار الى اقل من 55 مليجرام فا احنا
عندنا حمله باذن الله سنتقل قريبا من
المجلس الصحي السعودي ممثلا بمركز الوطني
للقلب اللي هي حمله 55 لجميع المرضى اللي
هم تم تشخيصهم بمتلازمه الشريان التاجي ان
احنا نبغى نصل بالكوليسترول الضار الى رقم
55 وعندنا الادويه التي تساعدنا على هذا
طبعا هي مش ادويه فقط همم
الاكل همم اول الغذاء الحركه وطبيعه هذا
طبيعه الحياه وجوده الحياه وايضا تعتقد
الى اي مدى هذه الطريقه هذه المعايير
الجديده اللي راح تعتمدوها من ناحيه
الطريقه العلاجيه
بالاضافه الى خطتكم الاخرى يعني ممكن تقلل
من من من هذه الاعداء يعني الاعداد
الكبيره اليوم
لو التقينا ان شاء الله بعد المعايير
انا اعتقد اذا التقينا بعد سنه نكون باذن
الله في وضع افضل بكثير من ناحيه عدد
المرضى المصابين بالجلطات القلبيه الحاده
عدد المرضى المصابين بجلطات قلبيه حاده
متكرره ونسبه الكوليسترول في الدم همم
طبعا احنا المعايير هذه المعاني بها
الحقيقه هو الممارس الصحي طبعا يعني امراض
القلب والشرايين همم لا ياتون فقط
لاطباء القلب ولكن ياتوا لي اطباء الرعايه
الصحيه الاوليه الاطباء الباطنيه واطباء
الطوارئ واحنا حقيقه عنينا في هذه
المعايير بانه احنا نبسط المساله بحيث انه
ليس فقط طبيب القلب يستفيد منه ولكن طبيب
القلب طبيب الرعايه الصحيه الاوليه طبيب
الباطنيه العامه وطبيب الطوارئ بحيث ان
احنا كلنا نتعاون ونتظافر الجهود بانه
والله اذا جاء مريض احنا فعلا كوليسترول
ونعرف ايش هي المعايير وكم الحد اللي احنا
لازم نحافظ عليه بالنسبه لكولسترول يعني
التوت الكوليست ولا اول كوليسترول الكلي
وايضا الكوليسترول الضار اللي هو اللودن
سيتي لايف وبروتين ال دي ال همم وهذا يعني
احنا حتى نبغى نبه الساده المشاهدين بانه
اذا رحت للطبيب واخذت تحليل الكوليسترول
ابحث عن ال دي ال وشوف الرقم واسال الطبيب
هل هذا هو الرقم هذا التارت هذا هو الهدف
اللي انا المفروض اصل له او احتاج او اعمل
شيء اخر شكرا لكم ان شاء الله نلتقي بعد
سنه باذن الله واحنا نبقى همم نقرا ارقام
مختلفه ويمكن نتكلم عن طرق نجاح هذا
الاستراتيجيه وهذه المعاه شكرا جزيلا لك
مدير عام المركز الوطني جدا الدكتور عادل
عبد القادر طاش